BRLL MAN WIT
RAN A RE LOST D  UTEASRIV
OPLE AT
SHELTER AND KILLING EIGHT OF
THEM, MOST OF WHOM WERE
VENEZUELANG TO
VIDEO OBTAINEDY
CNN SHARES A GROUPTRYI THE
THE CRASH.
WITNESSES SAY HED HI
VEHI TO BE .AYHE YELLED SCE OPP.
STAYING ON TEXAS MEXICO
BOTHERED SLEEP
ON TTRO TODAY,
A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AS THEDEMIC-ERA EALTHE
THS.T UNDER TRUM
THURSDAY NOT JUST ELTHIS SUR
TEXAS ON
DAY FRO PER DAYEKS OAN.McCULLU
N 35W , 1,000.
D CULVERO
WITH HARROWING OF  ON THE OTHER.
T THE U.S. SOUTHERN BORDER
ILNGS ONWATCH.VING A CLAWED THR
THE  WIRE, YOU CAN S W FRUSTRATH
OTHER TRAPPED IN A
METAL AT THE TEXASFROM ABOVE Y A
THE ONLY TWSING
THIS DAY AND THE CLOTH HE MILESA
MILES OF O.
FOR MANY MIGRANTS G UNTRIES LIKT
IN PLACES LIKE .SEE THE SI
IT'S FULL OFMP,
T TENTS.
'V
S THIS  TIS 22-YEOMR
HUSBAN4-YE-OTLE
GIRL HAVE CAMPED OUTE FO
THRE ALREADY.Y ARE GOIN CROSS
BUT DOT WANT T
ILLEGALLY.
SHE WANTS TO DO
HA . WHEN?>>epNT WEEKS THE
MIGRANTS NORTH OMEY TO DIGITAL H
ASYLUM OVERS.
O HAVE BEEN
WOMAN IS SURE SHE WILL ET ONE.LA
SHE AND
CARRY THE MARKS TO IT. TAROUNDNG
SH SHE HAS SOME BU
STILL ON FE  SUN
FROM B O TRAIN JOU TO JUAREZ FR
SOUTHERN MEXICO 10DR
NY RIDE THE RAIL T OF FREIGHT T.
WE CAUGHT UP WITH E  AS IT
WAS ARRIVING.
MIP HERE.
MANY OF THEM HAVE  THE
MOHA WOU OFO
EVERYT FLIKE ICE
HIS WHOLMINDE GOING TO STAY
GH CLEANED UP ANARE TO INTU.E BD
TO CLIMB DOWN.
ENCOURAGING AND TELLING HER
LET'S GO.
RTN JOURNEY RT
FO O CALLED TH
OFTENTY CARTELS.
HOURS MAKING TEATREKS SCARRINGIM
O
YS THEREN
TRAIN.HO H AND A HALF DAYS ON S
TRAIN.'SMERICAN
E INSSAY.
>>NOTHER 25 MILES
UNT SUN TO THE BORDEER
MO EP WHERE WETARTEDTHE BARBED .
NA. CENT M TEXAS
NOOP THE.S SLOW TM BIT.
THE YOUNG WOMAT
ATE A GATH
S OF
BEQUICK HUD EYUR ALONGLY TO TURN
S WHER
ENU  CPE ME, OTH S
WE CROSSR HERE
TIE  LHAT ALL THESE FOLKN T GO
IN FACT, TCK ON TITLE FOLKS WILL
PRELIMINILND FOR
THEIR SE TO BE P
HED,ND TITLE 42 THEY
WE SOME CASES IMMEDIATELY.WEVEO
8  AIR
BE B THEPROVE YLUM, THEY CAN